bonjour je ne vous attendait pas et bien
puisque j'étais en train de lire le
trône de fer faisons donc une vidéo sur
le sujet
[Musique]
ça faisait un moment déjà que je me
disais que je fais bien quelque chose
sur game of thrones
un peu comme ce que j'avais fait quand
j'avais raconté l'histoire des burgondes
sans cuillère et sans salsifis
sauf qu'il y aurait tellement de choses
à dire sur le lien entre game of thrones
l histoire on pourrait partir sur les
personnages historiques qui ont inspiré
des personnes de game of thrones les
peuples la justice les moeurs la société
et les loisirs la bouffe mais du coup la
vidéo aurait mis autant de temps à
sortir que le tome 6 qu'on attend
toujours
j'ai donc choisi de vous parler d
inspiration architecturale des bâtiments
et villes qui ont inspiré ceux de la
série mais comme encore une fois le
sujet était assez vaste on va chercher
ensemble lesquels sept merveilles du
monde se trouve dans game of thrones et
au passage on s'étendra quand même sur
la société et d'autres trucs qu'on n'est
pas juste là pour faire des top jeu
prévient aussi que la vidéo contiendra
quelques spoil donc mieux vaut être à
jour dans la série où vous entends
connaît la palourde avant de la regarder
et pour cette vidéo je serai en duplex
avec une invitée un petit peu spécial
arias que tu me reçoit wil perçoit très
bien mais c'est cathy 6 4 merci car on
se retrouve total est la première ville
que j'avais envie d'aborder et la
citadelle de villevieille qui n'apparaît
qu'à partir du dernier épisode de la
saison 6 lorsque ça me décide de s'y
rendre avec vers guily pour ceux qui
regardent que la série pour apprendre à
devenir un monstre villevieille est
situé dans le vif au sud-ouest de
westeros à l'embouchure du fleuve
hydromel qui malheureusement n'est pas
constitué du meilleur alcool du monde
comme son nom l'indiqué c'est la plus
ancienne cité fondée à westeros ainsi
que la plus grande et la plus riche
elle est fondée par les premiers hommes
et serait à l'origine un comptoir
commerçants qui se constitue en ville
par l'action des rails tower la famille
qui dirige ce territoire c'est donc
avant tout une ville portuaire mais qui
se démarquent par deux bâtiments hors du
commun
le premier est la grande tour un phare
de plus de 230 mètres de haut dans
lequel vit la famille hightower mais qui
sert également de cadrans solaires
marre de phare il est si haut qu'on
prétend pouvoir voir le mur depuis son
sommet et l'un d'entre eux puisqu'il ya
plusieurs phare successifs aurait été
construit par brandon le bâtisseur jeu
lui qui a construit un mur aussi
j'utilise beaucoup le conditionnel comme
vous l'aurez remarqué non pas parce que
je n'ai pas effectué des recherches de
qualité pour cet épisode mais parce que
georges martin reste dans le flou et
n'apporte pas de réponse claire quant à
l'origine de nombreux bâtiments
quand c'est pas les origines des
personnages tout court en tant que cité
plusieurs fois millénaire villevieille
possède sa part de mythes et de légendes
le deuxième lieu remarquable de
villevieille et sa citadelle un ensemble
de bâtiments qui sert de lieu de
formation aux maistre elle est fondée
par le roi eut rigole hightower qu'il
est son terrain aux érudits à la
recherche de connaissances
on y trouve entre autres un foyer du
scribe où les habitants peuvent
consulter des écrivains publics un
tribunal un centre de soins et surtout
une bibliothèque immense qui contient
des livres dont il s'agit parfois du
dernière exemplaire existant
c'est dans cette citadelle que les
novices acquiert les différentes
connaissances qui leur permettent de
former leurs chaînes de maistre elle est
constituée de différents métaux qui
correspondent à leurs capacités argent
pour la médecine sphère noire pour
l'élevage de corbeaux bronze pour
l'astronomie et c'est chaque maison
possède un maistre qui lorsqu'il
prononce ses voeux renonce à toute
ambition est prête allégeance au royaume
et au château auquel il est affecté mon
ordre sert certes mais qui le royaume du
mastering et winterfell j'additionne je
vous ai enseigné à lire écrire compter
l'histoire et le métier militaire
je vous aurais enseigne est bien
davantage si vous aviez manifesté la
moindre envie d'apprendre
je n'irai pas jusqu'à prétendre que je
vous aime de tout mon coeur mais je ne
saurait non plus vous haïr et voyez rech
que tant que vous tenez winterfell mais
veut m'obliger en conscience à vous
conseiller
aussi vous conseiller âge à présent de
vous rendre c'était peut-être pas une si
bonne idée de bâtard
partant john ils sont dirigés par un
archi maistre qui informe entre autres
le reste du royaume des changements
officiel de saison par l'envoi d'un
corbeau blanc
bref vous l'aurez peut-être déjà reconnu
villevieille
c'est alexandrie on y trouve non pas une
mais deux des sept merveilles du monde
pour info les sept merveilles du monde
sont une liste des oeuvres
architecturales les plus extraordinaires
du monde antique établi on sait pas trop
par qui elle date des environs du 3e
siècle avant jésus-christ et se
concentre sur des bâtiments remarquables
par leur gigantisme
plus c'est gros mieux c'est ils cassent
et où il est intéressant de constater
que l'univers de game of thrones dispose
de ses propres merveilles dont certaines
seront abordés ici il s'agit des neuf
merveille de l'homme issu d'un livre
ancien et qui compte les murailles de
kars les trois cloches de novos le long
pont de volantis la grande pyramide de
glisse le palet au message de sart nat
le mur les routes aériennes le titan de
bravos et des palais d'or de l'iti
alexandrie partage de très nombreux
points communs avec vivienne construite
en moins 331 sous l'impulsion
d'alexandre le grand qui aime laisser d
alexandrie un peu partout où il passe
elle est ensuite dirigé par les tollés
mais devient rapidement l'une des villes
les plus importantes de la méditerranée
elle est un grand pôle commercial grâce
à ces porcs est une ville très peuplées
qui compte environ cinq cent mille
habitants
strabon la surnomme le comptoir du monde
mais c'est pour son statut de capitale
culturelle cas nous à rester la plus
connue tous les mets premier décide de
la construction de la tour de l'île de
pharos qui donne son nom au phare son
but était de guider les navires bien sûr
mais aussi de symboliser la puissance de
sa dynastie est d'assurer à son fils le
titre de pharaon le maccabi listing de
mathieu brisson famille contrairement à
la tour de villevieille les ptolémées
n'y vivent pas et elle est aussi deux
fois plus petit mais c'est toujours plus
facile de faire du gigantisme dans un
livre que quand il faut porter les
pierres soi même le phare était
constitué de trois étages contre 7 pour
la tour de gilbert
parmi les sept merveilles la tour de
pharos est-elle édifier ce plus récent
elle est endommagée par des tremblements
de terre au 4e siècle et définitivement
détruites au 14e siècle encore à cause
de tremblement de terre est évidemment
la deuxième vers veille de ville
alexandrie est la bibliothèque qu'à
l'époque on appelait le musée j'en ai
déjà parlé dans ma vidéo du mois dernier
sur l'histoire des bibliothèques
alors je m'attendrais un petit peu moins
sur le sujet la construction du musée
est aussi initié par ptolémée premier il
ne s'agit pas uniquement d'une
bibliothèque mais aussi comme pour la
citadelle d'une école rassemblant des
savons venus de toute la méditerranée et
étudiants diverses matières comme les
mathématiques l'astronomie la médecine
l'objectif du musée était de posséder un
exemplaire de toutes les oeuvres
existantes dans le monde ce qui était
encore possible jusqu'à l'invention de
l'imprimerie si on en a vu les moyens et
c'est pourquoi le musée est aussi doté
d'ateliers de copistes qui est recopié
ses oeuvres en grec
il aurait possédé jusqu'à 700 milles
rouleau rassemblés dans la bibliothèque
mais aussi dans d'autres bâtiments
spécialisés
malheureusement sa bibliothèque est
aussi détruite ses connaissances avec
par plusieurs incendies est
définitivement avec la conquête arabe de
mais si on va un peu au-delà des 7
merveilles la citadelle devait vieille
peut aussi nous rappeler les maisons de
la sagesse ce sont des établissements
qui apparaissent en terre d'islam vers
le 9e siècle et qui rassemble à la fois
bibliothèque bien plus riche que ce qui
se faisait en occident la même époque
école centre de traduction dans les
maisons de la sagesse on enseigne encore
une fois la médecine la philosophie
l'astronomie la particularité de la
citadelle de villevieille et d'être
restreinte à un groupe précis et fermé
que les connaissances antique et
médiévale était accessible à tous avant
qu'ils souhaitaient les consulter par
contre pour devenir savant dans
l'antiquité ou en moyenne d'âge il
fallait généralement pas être un fils de
p corps que tout le monde peut tenter de
devenir mestreau s'ils le souhaitent
donc dans l'ensemble les deux se valent
pour la suite de notre voyage à travers
ou st rose je vous en mets de jardin
aquatique de dornes d'orner le
territoire situé tout au sud du
continent
dirigé par la famille martel sa capitale
et lens et lyon une cité où l'air elle
sait qu on transpire le cauchemar pour
les nordiques que je suis
al'inverse les jardins aquatiques même
s'ils ne se trouvent quelque 15
kilomètres de lens et lyon sont situés
en bordure de la merde et et bénéficie
donc d'une bonne petite brise marine
ils sont construits par le prince
marronne martel verlande de sang après
la conquête de l'ouest et n'ose parler
targuer
marc audemar tel est marié à une tare
guerrier n'daw nery ce n'est pas celle
que vous connaissez c'est par ce mariage
que d'ordre est rattachée aux sept
couronnes des targaryen ayant tenté la
conquérir auparavant mais son succès et
marotte martel fait construire ses
jardins en l'honneur de son épouse
les jardins aquatiques sont composés
d'une galerie à triples arcades
entourant desjardins qui comporte des
milliers des sens on y trouve aussi des
fontaines des bassins où les enfants
peuvent se baigner quelle que soit leur
origine sociale c'est la princesse
daenerys qui décident dès le départ dit
élever ses enfants et de laisser les
enfants de la noblesse d'orienne
profiter des jardins sont ouverts à tous
les enfants d'ornières par la suite ils
sont surplombées par un palais de marbre
rose dans l'histoire de game of thrones
qui racontait dans la série et des
livres on est aux environs de l'an 300
le prince daurade martel décide de
délaisser lens et lyon pour s'installer
définitivement au jardin aquatique
parce qu'il souffre de la goutte et
aussi parce que comme ça ses ennemis
politiques seront moi au courant de son
état de santé réel qu'il ne sert pas
tant que ça en fin de compte
voilà donc vous laisse les jardins
aquatiques peuvent être rapprochés de
plusieurs jardins historiques les
premiers les plus évidents et qui ont
entre autres servi de le tournage à la
série sont les jardins du palais de
l'alcazar de séville des vergers ils
sont plantés dès le viiie siècle dans de
la conquête arabe puis amélioré au
deuxième siècle sous le roi hamad est
complétée du palais de l'alcazar sous le
roi pierre 1er de castille de nos jours
on y trouve de nombreux jardins issus de
la renaissance ce qui fait d'elle cazin
un mélange de traditions chrétiennes et
musulmanes des différentes époques
ces jardins sont classés au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco depuis 1972
même s'ils ne se trouvent pas en bord de
mer contrairement aux jardins aquatiques
l'eau et tient aussi une place
importante puisqu'on y trouve de
nombreux bassins est un système
d'irrigation perfectionner bien moins
connu l'alcazaba d'almeria a aussi servi
de décor pour le tournage de la série d'
influence des jardins aquatiques est
donc clairement andalouse mais ce goût
pour desjardins grandiose entourant
palais nous renvoie à une référence
beaucoup plus ancienne et qui nous
rapproche des sept merveilles du monde à
nouveau il s'agit des jardins suspendus
de babylone qui aurait été édifié par le
roi nabuchodonosor ii dans une région
désertique et en l'honneur de sa femme
qui venait du
région beaucoup plus verte du coup le
background se rapproche un peu plus des
jardins aquatiques
il serait donc dates et des environs de
580 avant jésus-christ et sont décrits
comme une construction carrée d'environ
120 m de côté en brique au sommet de
laquelle se trouverait des jardins et
bassins poussant sur des terrasses de
différents niveaux des descriptions des
jardins sont peu précises et pour cause
il s'agit de la seule des sept
merveilles dans l'existence est
fortement remise en question les sources
antiques qui mentionne ces jardins comme
diodore de sicile aux travaux dans son
pas contemporain et s'inspire de sources
beaucoup plus ancienne et disparus ce
qui est pratique hérodote qui visait
babylone au vème siècle avant
jésus-christ ne fait aucune mention des
jardins alors qu'il décrit la ville en
long en large et en travers
l'emplacement de babylone a été
redécouvert au début du 20e siècle mais
aucun chantier de fouille a permis de
découvrir l'emplacement de ces jardins
les centaines de tablettes datant de
l'époque de n'a pu que nos hors d'eux et
qui mentionne ces constructions dans
font pas mention
c'est louche pour certains chercheurs et
pourrait en fait s'agir des jardins
suspendus de ninive qui se trouve quand
même à 440 kilomètres de babylone ces
jardins sont décrits dans un bas relief
du palais de sanaa chéri par un roaa
syrien du 7e siècle et correspondent pas
mal aux descriptions condat du jardin de
babylone
d'autant que ce serait pas la première
fois des auteurs antiques confondent les
deux villes j'ai surélever les abords du
palais il sera une merveille pour tous
les peuples
j'ai construit un jardin surélevé qui
imitent les chaînes de là bas nous les
plantes et de toutes les essences
aromatiques d'arbres fruitiers d'arbres
qui font la richesse des montagnes de
babylone ainsi que des arbres qui donne
de la laine dans le cas de ninive on
sait que les jardins ont existé ils
étaient érigés par des systèmes de
canaux et d'aqueduc parce que la région
était particulièrement inhospitalière
on ignore cependant s'il s'agit des
jardins décrit par les auteurs antiques
et l'existence de jardin à ninive
n'empêche pas l'existence de jardin à
babylone vestaires donc et on peut
retenir que la légende autour des
jardins suspendus de babylone semble
avoir fortement inspiré les jardins
aquatiques dedans passons maintenant sur
l'autre continent avec la cité libre de
bravo et pour ça nous pouvons reprendre
notre duplex arias est ce que tu nous
reçoit oui je dis de m'appeler katyn
quand tu veux savoir qu'à sur bravo
savait pas longtemps je suis arrivé tout
puisque tu peux nous parler de
l'apparence de la ville eh bien je me
trouve actuellement devant le long canal
pas très loin du marché aux poissons
j'aimerais bien vous faire bénéficier de
l'odeur la ville est composé d'un tas de
petites digues reliées entre elles par
des ponts et des canaux est entourée
d'une agglo qui la protège de la pleine
mer il trouve un port de guerre un port
de contrôle douanier un port pour les
navires de bravo importe pour les
navires étrangers au monde
et puisque la ville est assez
cosmopolite on trouve un pas de temps
que j'ai tous les dieux existants même
si n'existe qu'un soldat dieu le dieu
l'âme
merci cat la cité libre de bravo s'est
créé environ 800 ans avant le début de
la série par des esclaves en fuite
elle demeure au départ une cité secrète
durant cent onze ans jusqu'à ce que le
seigneur de la ville décide de la
révéler au monde en prenant soin de
rembourser au passage des navires voler
un siècle plus tôt
c'est donc la ville la plus récente de
toutes les cités libre des sauces le
continent est la seule qui n'ait jamais
été possédés par valeria ville d'origine
des targuets ses habitants sont issus de
peuples divers de religions diverses
elle devient rapidement l'un des plus
grands ports du monde un grand centre
commercial doté aussi d'une flotte de
pêche et de guerre importante elle
refuse toujours de commercer avec des
sites et esclavagiste est interdit d'
esclavage qui est logique vu le passé de
la ville elle est dirigée par un
seigneur de la mère choisit parmi les
riches familles de la ville
on ne peut pas parler de bravo sans
mentionner la banque de faire
l'institution presque aussi ancienne que
la ville et qui prêtent de l'argent dans
le monde entier en veillant toujours à
bien récupérer son dû pour ça elle
dispose de sa propre flotte et
n'hésitent pas à recourir à des
assassinats ou des renversements pouvoir
en cas de non remboursement
ça ne rend pas l'argent mais je peux les
comprendre enfin on trouve en ville
d'état vers des auberges des bordels et
des tas de chat par tous amis c'est pour
ça car y'a qu'ils essayent de m'attraper
lui
bravo c'est aussi connu pour son titans
une statue de granit gigantesque qui
enjambe l'entrée de la ville servant à
la fois de phares et des ouvrages
défensifs puisqu'il est creuset de
meurtrières et le rgi matin et soir et
chaque fois qu'un navire entre dans la
lagune
certains lui prêtent même la capacité de
se déplacer mais ce n'est bien qu'une
statue n'est pas dans les argonautes
[Musique]
on ne connaît pas sa taille exacte
probablement une centaine de mètres de
haut il pourrait facilement en jambes et
les murailles de winter fun mais je sais
que tu l'a déjà dit là évidemment
l'occitan de bravo s'est fortement
inspiré d'une autre des sept merveilles
le colosse de rhodes contrairement aux
titans qui ne représente pas vraiment un
dieu bravo sonoran tous les dieux le
colosse de rhodes est une représentation
du dieu du soleil
hélios il est construit par charrettes
de lindon sur l'île de rhodes verte 292
avant jésus-christ pour célébrer la
résistance de la ville durant un siège
d'un dans a posé par les macédoniens
sa construction est compliqué le colosse
mesure environ 30 mètres de haut et
comporte d'abord un squelette de voir
ensuite recouvert de plaques de bronze
du fait de sa fragilité il à merveille
la plus éphémère du monde soixante-six
ans après sa construction un tremblement
terre le casse au niveau des genoux qui
restent sur leur socle jusque 654 avant
de disparaître à leur tour un point pour
bravo ce contrairement aux titans aussi
il ne se tenait probablement pas les
jambes écartées à l'entrée du port cette
image apparaît à la renaissance mais vu
les matériaux utilisés et la taille
modeste du colosse par là peu
envisageable
il était probablement plus tôt à
l'entrée du port façon statue de la
liberté ou sur les hauteurs de l'est
même si on s'éloigne encore un peu des
sept merveilles je ne peux pas finir sur
bravo sans mentionner l'autre analogie
entre cette ville et l'histoire bien de
chez nous bravo c'est clairement venise
à l'image de bravo venise est construite
à partir de quelques îlots protégés de
l'adriatique par une lagune
même si elle est déjà occupé par
quelques pêcheurs autant l'empiré romain
elle émerge surtout à partir du 6e
siècle à cause des invasions lombarde
qui oblige les locaux allaient
s'installer sur place parce que c'est
plus safe c'est déjà difficile d'y
mettre les pieds sont mis
la ville est donc tout comme bravo ce
multipolaire indépendante est constitué
de différentes il pond et canaux elle se
développe d'abord avec la vente de sel
et à partir du 11e siècle elle devient
l'une des plus grandes cités maritimes
intermédiaire commercial entre l'orient
et l'occident
elle est dirigée par les grandes
familles marchandes qui élisent le doj
avis comme un bravo se dit donc comme un
brave hausse toujours on y trouve un
arsenal dans lequel on peut construire
jusqu'à 200 navires à la fois des chats
partout et des banques importantes elles
déclinent cependant au xvème siècle avec
la montée de l'empiré ottoman
l'ouverture de la route des indes et la
découverte de l'amérique qui transfère
le commerce vers l'atlantique dans
l'univers de game of thrones on trouve
aussi des pyramides toujours sur le
continent des sauces des sauces kebab la
plus ancienne à la grande pyramide de
guise qui était la capitale de
l'empirique disparue qui dominait avant
l'ascension de valérien elle figure
parmi les neuf merveilles de l'univers
de gammarth ronde mais elle est détruite
depuis 5000 ans au moment de la série
elle était une résidence royale
un trek à partage avec la grande
pyramide de merine qui s'en inspire
fortement mérine est aussi une cité très
ancienne prestigieuse du temps de
l'empiré biscary mais qui perd en
richesse après sa chute et se replient
alors sur le commerce d'esclaves à
l'époque qui nous intéresse
elle n'a plus droit depuis dix mille ans
et nombreuses pyramide à degrés de la
ville sont les demeures des grands
maîtres de birine permis
la grande pyramide se trouve au coeur de
la cité elle mesure environ 240 mètres
de haut et serait parti de base en eau
entre des écuries et entrepôts des
salles d'entraînement des appartements
pour les autres une salle d'audience et
des jardins en terrasse elle est
administrée par un sénéchal choisi parmi
les grands maîtres jusque là conquête de
la ville par dani reese qui a un talent
ça court dans la pyramide et prend la
place de rain les pyramides de l'univers
de game of thrones sont donc plutôt des
lieux de résidence et de pouvoir la
forme pyramidale étant propice à évoquer
la masse et à durer dans le temps
les pyramides de notre monde garde cette
idée d'éternité mais ont des fonctions
très différentes
la pyramide de gizeh la seule des sept
merveilles encore debout est un tombeau
monumental bâti vers 2500 avant
jésus-christ elle mesure 146 mètres de
haut soit 100 m de moins de sel que
mairie mais encore une fois c'est plus
facile quand on a juste à décrire la
pyramide que quand il faut la construire
des pyramides égyptiennes étaient donc
des tombeaux et non des lieux de
résidence qui succède au mas tabac les
premières formes de sépulture et qui
précède des tombeaux plus discrets comme
ceux de la vallée des rois et des reines
cette fonction de tombeau se retrouvent
dans les pyramides nubienne chinoise
jusqu'au nouvel engouement pour les
pyramides au 19e siècle qui amène à la
construction de tombes en forme de
pyramide comme celle de castro qui
abrite le fondateur de la ville dans les
civilisations aztèques et mayas les
pyramides avait différentes fonctions
mais jamais de résidence comme i'm here
in non non ce sont des temples des
tombes délai cérémoniel sacrificielle
des postes d'observation du ciel les
pyramides aztèques et mayas
n'apparaissent pas du tout en même temps
ne sont pas du tout le fruit des
atlantes unis des extraterrestres merci
bien le point commun entre toutes ces
pyramides terrestre et game of thrones
et leur caractère imposant et officiels
ne sont pas des bâtiments du commun la
complice des fonctions importantes ne
sont pas destinés aux premiers décors
venues sauf les pyramides de la grande
motte a très envie de partir sur une
comparaison grande motte péril et enfin
même s'il ne s'apparentent à aucune des
sept merveilles je voulais quand même
vous parlez du mur fait partie des neuf
merveilles de l'univers de la mort ce
tronçon de par son gigantisme et
l'ampleur de sa réalisation comme pour
la plupart des merveilles terrienne et
de là bas il mesure environ 210 mètres
de haut une hauteur si hallucinante que
même george martin a reconnu
j'ai un peu exagéré il coupe tout le
nord de westeros de tours ombreux zafour
le vent sur 450 km de long sa
particularité est d'être entièrement
construit en bloc de glace
recouvert d'une autre couche de glace
qui lui donne son aspect lisse il est
érigé environ 8000 en avoir d'autres
époques peu après la longue nuit un
épisode sombre de l'histoire de west &
ross c'est pour ça qu'on l'appelle
l'hiver il était pire que jamais et les
marcheurs blanc descendirent vers le sud
en tuant tous les premiers hommes t1
sauvage
je suis du peuple libre une vraie
nordique cuba excuse moi je suis
derrière aussi bref c'est pas exactement
ce qui s'est passé pendant la longue
nuit mais il en résulte la fondation de
la garde de nuit et la construction du
mur par brandon le bâtisseur fondateur
semi légendaire de la maison stark
il aurait été aidé par les enfants de la
forêt par des géants le mur ne serait
pas seulement fait de glace mais aussi
de sortilège qui empêche de laisser
passer les autres et nous aussi
il est gardé par 17 former sa défense
dix minutes sous les targaryen puis sous
les pas rater dans game of thrones le
mur sert donc à empêcher tous ceux qui
se trouvent de l'autre côté de passer il
peut nous évoquer en cela la grande
muraille de chine bâti pour défendre la
frontière nord quelle coïncidence mais
date de construction sont nombreuses car
plusieurs muraille ont été construites
au viiie siècle avant jésus-christ au 3e
siècle avant jésus-christ la muraille
telle qu'on la connaît datent de la
dynastie ming est construite aux 15ème
siècle elle fait maintenant partie des
sept merveilles du monde moderne en tant
que plus long ouvrage construit par des
humains de nombreuses civilisations ont
aussi construit des murs pour se
protéger de ce qui se trouve l autre
côté on trouve des murailles en inde par
exemple
pourtant le mieux rappelle surtout le
mur d'hadrien déjà par la forme de west
héros ce qui ressemble vachement la
grande bretagne on retrouve l'idée d'un
peu plus de redick plus sauvageons que
les gentils romain civilisé
la présence de fortin à intervalles
réguliers mais progressivement abandonné
comme sur le mur mais le mur d'hadrien
n'était pas pour autant un mur
uniquement défensif il était beaucoup
plus ouvert sur le nord que notre mur de
glace et servez aussi bien de postes de
frontière que de lieu de transit pour
les commerçants qui se rendaient dans le
nord
j'en ai déjà parlé dans ma vidéo sur le
mur d'hadrien qui date depuis un moment
alors je vais pas m'étendre plus là
dessus et je vous invite à aller la
regarder alors si votre mur était plutôt
sympa en fin de compte on peut savoir
pourquoi le mien nous interdit
formellement passé parce que vous n'êtes
pas les seuls dont on se protège il
starck pour moi tu n'es personne mon
courage avec les marcheurs blanc moi je
file à dornes pareil cas des jardins
sympa
désolé c'était une intervention non
prévue ça va très bien mettre personne
en ce moment merci pour le coup de barre
alors et tu me dis quand tu repasses
d'andorre très bien faisons comme sa
balade paris champagne
le
ça
non
[Musique]
seule celle là